I deliberately did not feed you too much
unless you ask because it's actually
really important from here as soon as
you look at the first line and maybe
some of you experience this you're like
I don't know where they go I can't I
can't do exactly what we did before and
I hope you understand that moment that
you're in of like I'm sort of pushing in
something and I it's not giving that's
when you're doing real mathematics when
it doesn't feel like you're making very
much progress but you're staring really
hard if I told you really
straightforward
okay do this and then listen in this you
are not doing mathematics you up being a
machine and frankly the machines will
out machine you okay I was trying to
make you that I try to help you think
look at this live for a second the most
glaring problem that I have that stops
me from doing anything with this is that
this differs from the original example
in a key way namely it's a bit more
messy than what I started with this is a
really nice simple quadratic because it
has a 1 hiding out there what is it
called again
it's Manik right this could be Manik if
a is equal to 1 but you don't know that
right so as mathematicians like to do
you turn a problem that is difficult and
messy into one that you already know how
to solve you don't like that being an A
then that's cool we can get rid of it
how I can divide through right remember
that right hand side is 0 you can divide
it by anything you like except 0 and it
would stay the same right so I'm going
to divide everything through this is
what my first line of working would be
happy with that do you agree it hasn't
been changed now I admit it's a bit of a
counterintuitive first step because we
usually I mean we labored the point this
morning we don't like fractions we get
rid of them everywhere we possibly can
however what I've traded is
fractions are messy but now it's monic
right so I can treat this just like the
problem I have before
ok let's start to pursue when I had x
squared plus 6x minus 11 what was the
first thing I did I got rid of the 11
over the other side right so here is the
constant term you know it's the constant
because there's no X terms attached to
it very good so that leaves me with an x
squared plus B on x over there and a
minus C on a over there ok now at this
point we added 9 how did you know to add
9 yes
yep your heart and then you squared you
have these squares so what is 1/2 of B
or nay
I think it's beyond to a right B on to a
that's 1/2 and then use is very there
you go now you may well be able to UM
square that pilot and square it in your
head and that's good for you but I've
always found outer things like this
really difficult to keep in my head and
do accurately I've written an extra step
in this case if you've on out of this
dough for you by the way you're gonna
add it over here as well in this case
I'm actually at a bit of an advantage
because if you didn't write this as B
squared on 4a squared which is what
happens when you square where you can
just go straight to this next line it's
already in the form that you wanted
isn't it what's the factorization
x+ beyond to a and then the whole thing
is squared
do you agree there's a look so we just
did the factorization on the left on the
right hand side you have these two gross
guys but I think they can talk thick and
tall because what's this denominator
gonna be this one's here
now before I squared right so it will be
B squared on 4a squared that's okay I
can make it talk to that what am I gonna
have to multiply numerator denominator
by it'll be for a right
oh wait for AC huh that looks familiar
right we know where we hit it right
whenever you have to prove your result
you should have one eye on the algebra
and the other eye on where am I going
where am I going and that's a bit of a
signal that these are looking group on
for AIDS okay what would you like me to
do next
on the left hand side I think I'm just
going to leave him be for a second on
the right hand side the whole point of
those common denominators was so that I
could combine them and this one's so
thank you so might as well put him
second b squared minus 4ac that's
promising
do you member that denominator it's 4 I
squared now but where did it come from
again it came from 2a or squared that
should set off alarm bells as well right
if I write that is it should pay o
squared remember what's on the left hand
side okay now just look carefully line 1
line 2 line 3 line 4 line 5 which of
these lines am i up to right now and
yeah the count gets that how do I know
where am I in this proof I think I'm at
this line on time you see I've got
something squared and then there's
something else on the right hand side
before I get to this square root okay so
I'm going to take the square root of
both sides that leaves you with this
okay on the right hand side oh good plus
or minus the square root see your memory
is key in what about the denominator
what's the square root of the square of
2 a 2 a right now by the way let me just
point out have to be a little bit
careful here this is actually not 100%
true because just suppose if a were
equal to negative 5 what's the square
root of the square of a think about it
for a second do it once at a time
you square it and it becomes 20 fun and
then you take the square root and as we
would just point out because of an X
question before you get five that's not
a is it right why is it okay in this
case there's something I've already
written on this line that makes it to a
pair see this guy here okay yeah what
this means is I want both of them I want
the plus and the minus right so this
means you know what whichever one you
want
I've got them covered okay that plus or
minus kind of what rescues you next week
we're going to spend a little more time
talking about absolute values because
the fact this is one of the definitions
of the absolute value function but we're
getting ahead of ourselves
so just farther away we'll come back
that's like what I need to do I'm pretty
much at the code for now I just have to
make X the subject which means you just
subtract that from both sides
conveniently in math and everything is
nothing is it convenience nothing is a
coincidence I've got to a center
nominator so there is the quadratic
formula in general involved